نعود الى العمليه العسكريه التركيه
الجاريه في شمال سوريا ينضم الينا من عمان
اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي مرحبا بك لواء فايز ما الذي
لفتك اليوم في هذه العمليه في يومها
السابع
الاستمرار لعمليات القصف الجوي المكثف
وبدات تعزيزه بالقذف المدعي والصاروخي
ولكن هناك تحضير يعني نقول في البعد
السياسي الامر محسوم لكن في البعد التقني
التنفيذي هناك لا يزال دراسه معلقه
للارتدادات على اي عمليه اجتياح بري فنحن
بين نقف بين موقف سياسيا واضح وبين موقف
الخبراء الانبيين
والاستراتيجيين والعسكريين الذي عليهم ان
يدرسوا تاثير وما هي الانتدابات
المتوقعه
والردود المتوقعه وارتداداتها وهذا قد
يجعلها في نقطه وسطيه ما بين الحمل الجوي
والقصف المدعي وما بين الرغبه السياسيه
ماذا اعني بذلك لانه اذا نظرنا الى
الخارطه من جراب حتى البحر المتوسط تقريبا
نصف المسافه 450 كيلو متر وهذه فيها نقطه
ضعف واحده وهي مطار منغ وتلفعه
وتتواجد فيها القوات الروسيه والميليشيات
الايرانيه اذا سيطرت عليها تكون قد سيطرت
على النصف الغربي من الحدود اذا نظرنا
شرقا هناك ثلاثه مناطق تعتبر مناطق ساخنه
وهي عين العرب
وعموده وعين عيسى اذا ما سيطرت عليها
فكانها تفتت المنطقه الشرقيه وقد يرى ان
هذا التوجه هو الذي قد يحدث ليس عمليه
اجتياح بري كامل لمسافه 4 كيلو متر شرق
الفراق انما عمليات جراحيه انتقاليه
هل تتحقق اهداف هذه العمليه من وجهه النظر
التركيه بالاع فقط على السلاح الجوي
والمدفعي
لا اذا ارادوا تامين مطلق كامل عليهم ان
ينفذوا عمليه بريه ولو محدوده واذا نفذت
العملي البريه المحدوده تكون في اربعه
مناطق ثلاثه مناطق شر من جرابلس شرقا شرق
الفرات ياخذ عين العرب ياخذ عين عيسى ياخذ
عامود وقد ياخذ المالكيه وهي نقاط ساخنه
تتواجد فيها قوات همم اسد او ما يطلق عليه
البي واي دي همم حمايه الشعب الكردي واخذ
منطقه عفرين عفوا تل رفعت مطار من غرب
الني- غرب نهر الفرات هنا تكون سيطرت على
الجزء الغربي وتتحكم الى درجه ماء في
الجزء الشرقي من نهر الفرات
فائز همم رده الفعل رده فعل قوات الكرديه
التي تتعرض لهذه الضربات
قوه رديت الفعل في البيدانيا رد فعل محدود
وبدا يتباطئ لانه اي تصعيد من قبلهم
سيقابل بتصعيد اكثر وافراط في استخدام
القوه وابتعاد الاطراف الداعمه هي الان
تراهن على امرين تراهن على المواقف
الدوليه
انطلاقا من انها تتحدث الان ان داعش موجود
وداعش يتحرك وانا انشغاله في قتال الجيش
التركي
داعش وفجر داعش الجديد النقطه الثانيه
السجون التي توجد فيها يوجد بها المقاتلين
وقياديين من داعش وسجن الهون الذي يوجد به
عائلات تعود الى همم اشخاص قدموا من الغرب
انها يمكن ان يطلق سراح بعض هؤلاء
وبالتالي هي تحاول ان تضغط على الدول
الرافضه للتدخل تركي لمنع تركيا وليس
الاكتفاء بالرقص شكرا جزيلا لك لواء فايز
الدويري الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
ضيفنا من عمان